with the increase in data exchange in
the current thick era we require proper
protocols and functions to maintain data
exchange
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to remiss an update
from us
now without further ado let's take a
look at the agenda for today's session
to start with we will understand what is
a protocol
then continue
with the types of protocol available in
a network channel
then we will start with what is the
sliding protocol
then look into the working procedure or
sliding window protocol
and ending a session with difference
between stop and wait protocol
and sliding window protocol
let's begin with the first heading that
is what is our protocol
as we know in a networking concept
protocols refers to the rules and
instructions
that governs the data transmission
between different network models and
devices in a communication channel
the data transmitted using protocols is
easily handled
and is reliable to use
as well as it provides a secure channel
for the data to be transmitted
now let's move on to the different types
of protocols available in a network
channel
the protocols available in a network
channel can be divided into two
different types
noiseless channels and noisy channels
where the noise part refers to any
external interference data error or
duplicate transmission in the network
channel
furthermore noiseless channels and noisy
channels can be divided into
subdivisions let's take a look at the
noiseless channels first
noiseless channels can be divided into
two types
simplest type and stop in weight type
whereas noisy channels are divided into
three subdivisions
stop and wait arq go back
and arq
selective repeat arq
in the noisy channel go back in ar queue
and
selective repeat arq are the ones that
apply the sliding window protocol for
data transmission over the network
channel
now let's look into some information
regarding sliding window protocol
to begin with the sliding window
protocol is a technique that allows the
share of multiple data frames in a
network channel
where the number of frames shared is
determined by the windows size assigned
to the network channel
also the frames sent during transmission
are assigned with a sequence number for
efficient frame transmission in the
communication channel
till this point in the video we have
already learned about the definition of
what is the sliding window protocol
now let's look into the working steps of
the sliding window protocol
to begin with we have a center site and
a receiver site in the network channel
then we require the frames where each
frame is given a sequence number
for this example we are using 0 to 8
which means a total of 9 frames are
available at the sender side
then using the window size we determine
the number of frames that can be shared
at an instance
for example we'll be using 3 as a window
size for this
example let's start with sending the
first frame that is 0
to the
receiver side
after the frame is sent a sliding window
appears on the number of frames
now let's move on to the next
that is frame one
the point to be noted is
before receiving any acknowledgement we
have to send all the frames that are
available according to the window size
that is for this example the window size
is 3 that means we have to send
three frames before we receive any
acknowledgement from the receiver side
let's send the last frame that is frame
2
now we have to wait for the receiver
side to send the acknowledgement signal
to the sender site before we can send
the next frame now that we have shared
the maximum number of frames the
receiver end will share the
acknowledgement signal for frame 0 with
the sender side
after this acknowledgement is received
by the sender side we can share the next
frame in the list that is frame 3
after the frame 3 has been sent
see the positioning of the sliding
window
the sliding window now changes from 0 1
2 to 1 to 1 3 frame
this positioning of the sliding window
represents that 0th frame has already
been acknowledged by the receiver side
whereas the third frame is sent for
acknowledgement from the receiver side
by the sender side
and similarly we have to do the same
pattern for the next two frames that is
frame number one and frame number
now the center side will receive the
acknowledgement for
frame 1 from the receiver side
and we can send frame 4 from the sender
side to the receiver side
now see the movement of the sliding
window
the sliding window changes from
1 to 1 3 frame number to 2 3 and 4.
similarly we can move on to the last
frame
now let's draw some simple conclusion
from all the working steps we have seen
so far
to begin with
frame number 1 and 0 represents the
acknowledged frames
whereas the frames within the sliding
window represents
the frames that awaiting acknowledgement
whereas the remaining frames 5 6 7 and 8
are not yet shared with the receiver
site
now let's move on to the next heading
for the session
difference between stop and wait
protocol and sliding window protocol
the first comparison is on the basis of
working mechanism
where the stop and weight protocol is
designed to send the data frame at a
single time
and wait for the receiver to send the
acknowledgement to share the next frame
as for the sliding window protocol
sender can send multiple frames
simultaneously and then wait for the
corresponding acknowledgement from the
receiver end
let's move on to the next comparison
that is based on the window size
on the basis of window size the stop and
rate protocol is always fixed at 1.
as for sliding window protocol as we saw
in earlier slides it varies according to
the scenario in the network channel
let's take a look at some other
comparisons too
the next comparison is based on
efficiency and time delay
as comparison on this basis the stop and
rate protocol is efficiently low and
suffers from more time delay
as for sliding window protocol the
efficiency is higher than the stop and
weight protocol which provides lower
time delay
during data transmission
let's move on to the last comparison
sorting and transmission of data
for stop and weight protocol sorting is
not required
and it applies half duplex system for
data transmission
as for sliding window protocol we
require sorting for better efficiency
and is full duplex in nature
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here